il est plus que urgent de revenir et de
se recentrer sur le paludisme sinon on
va continuer à compter le nombre de
morts
[Musique]
mon père était déjà professeur de
biologie animale donc du coup quand j'ai
fini ma formation que j'ai eu mon bac je
me suis un titan biologie animale puis
c'est après que la passion est venue je
veux pas dire quand ça commençait mais
je me suis rendu compte que je me
sentais bien quand je t'ai dans un
laboratoire je me sentais bien quand
j'étais en train de chercher à résoudre
un problème dans un laboratoire
[Musique]
l'un des principal vecteur du
paludisme l'anophèle femelle qu'on
appelle Anne et
c'est un vecteur très résistant au gel
insecticide chimique on utilise le plus
en plus et alors ma recherche
permet de trouver des solutions pour
contrer cette résistance ma ma recherche
se tourne vers des plantes comment
utiliser les plantes pour produire un
insecticide naturel
biologique qui sera respectueux de
l'environnement préfecture de la santé
de l'homme mais qui nous permettra de
combattre le vecteur qui est
là ça veut dire la première étape du
moustique avant qu'il ne soit adultes
qui ont réussi à à diminuer le nombre de
l'art on aura diminue le nombre de
moustiques adultes ça veut dire que - 2
nautiques Asus moins de piqûres de
moustiques mon mieux effectivement c'est
juste une auquel on associe
la technologie à particules pour booster
leur énergie et pour optimiser
l'efficacité des
éléments qui sont présents dans la
plante et qui peuvent avoir une action
sur ces moustiques si c'est l'heure de
moustique il y a le
citronnier et oranger en fait on teste
toutes les plantes qui peuvent avoir la
cité
[Musique]
le paludisme c'est vraiment vraiment un
problème
de santé publique au Cameroun
plusieurs des forces on fait dans le
domaine pratiquer le paludisme et encore
la bonne nouvelle du vaccin mais
beaucoup des fois reste à faire et je
pense qu'il est important que on attend
sur la recherche au niveau de la lutte
antivectorielle et moi je me suis tourné
vers cette recherche parce que le
paludisme continue à tuer alors nous
avons les moyens de pouvoir arrêter cela
l'objectif de ce travail c'est déjà de
le constituant un super grand projet qui
va créer des emplois à court terme qu'on
puisse déjà sortir le bien fait ici de
du laboratoire qu'ils deviennent ils
partent d'une invention à une innovation
que si je suis arrivé à ce stade
pourquoi pas les choses et je j'essaie
de trouver les moyens déjà en 2020 la la
journée le paludisme on avait organisé
un symposium où on essayait de
sensibiliser les jeunes femmes il est
très important que nous soyons
accompagné donc le gouvernement que des
mécènes que des personnes concernées et
nous accompagne pour que la science ce
soit vrai véritablement un objet de
tout pour faire évoluer la frite